[Applause]
some of you guys have requested for us
to make a video about France now France
is one of the wealthiest countries in
the world yet one with some of the
hardest economic problems today France
is the second largest economic power in
the European Union but that might not
last for much longer their youth
unemployment rate is over 23% and their
public debt is twice as big as their
entire GDP just 15 years ago the entire
world with buying Renault cars or
Alcatel mobile phones but today French
experts have formed the heart of what
they used to be just a short time ago
their companies are simply unable to
face the competition that's coming from
China from South Korea robbed even from
the United States and Germany
and as you can imagine this economic
crisis has had a great effect on French
society if you don't believe me let's
just have a look at the presidential
elections of this year that's 2017 none
of the candidates from the traditional
parties have made it to the second round
French voters are simply fed up with
their political establishment and this
is why they've chosen a politician who
wants to make a 180 shift in the French
system now you might be wondering what
are the reasons behind this French
crisis and more importantly what does
McCrone propose in order to solve it all
today we're going to answer that
question but before you started as usual
let's take a look at the history France
is - the French people right after World
War 2 all the European powers were on
the verge of bankruptcy then this
included France half the country was
destroyed by bombing and this included
houses as well as factories luckily
enough though but Uncle Sam was there
and then he was ready to help
the United States was interested in
having a strong Europe so that the
continent could purchase goods from the
misled duty so-called Marshall plan
being put into place it was a cash
injection of billions of dollars which
would lead to the reconstruction of the
European nation but still hold on just a
minute because each of these countries
use the finance in very different ways
for instance the German government
created their own political theory
called Auto liberalism aka social
liberalism this was a combination of
social programs and free enterprise in
other words the government would provide
a safety net for their citizens and
subsidize the companies as well but on
the other hand these companies were
private and they could compete with each
other boss was a very very different
case back then the president was General
Charles de Gaulle and he was no friend
of free enterprise
so his political theory dear ridges and
was pretty different from that as a
German cabinet is not giving proposals
but to give orders so de Beaune used all
of this money from the United States to
nationalize the big corporations steel
factories electric companies phone
companies even the car making beer moths
like Renault Persia and Citroen they all
had the government as their biggest
shareholder but not only that they also
created a dear rigid system on society
where the state would play a major role
in all areas including conditions for
hiring workers as well as the minimum
wage this is a really important point
because not all welfare states are
created the same in Germany there is no
minimum wage and there was a bigger
space trade unions and companies to
negotiate contract conditions further
health care was provided by private
insurance and regional governments had a
lot to say when it came to laws and
regulations nevertheless in France all
of the social policies came from the
central authority in other words the
goal represents kind of the opposite of
what we like our official politics
but despite all of that during these
first few years after World War two
prong centers be social Gloria 34 three
decades the average wage tripled and
those companies sponsored by the
government became global leaders
[Music]
this gives them context this was way
before American company started moving
their factories to China nano in
Michelin were opening factories in Spain
where salaries were much lower but let's
be honest during that time every
European country was growing at the same
rate just think about it we're talking
about the 1960s
Dasia was not the economic powerhouse
than it is today Latin America was full
of dictatorships of all kinds and the
Soviet Union was simply unable to
produce high enough quality goods to be
sold in the international market
nonetheless France had an important
industrial tradition it had a
well-educated society and overall it had
good rule of law and a stable political
system for companies and not only that
in 1958 of those countries already
rebuilt by the Marshall Plan decided to
create a free trade union which would
eventually become the European Union at
this time France had the largest
population of these countries and don't
forget the back in that time Germany was
still divided it's too hard all of this
meant that France was in the strongest
positions you negotiate their entry
conditions and as I said before Charles
the goal with no fan of free trade
he uses negotiating how to make France
the dominant country in certain
industries such as agriculture to shout
Europe Europe Europe that doesn't help
to anything or means anything so if you
are watching this video from anywhere in
Europe you might have heard about the
Common Agricultural Policy this is a
policy created in European consumers
from buying agricultural goods from the
developing world but not only that it
also imposes production quotas inside of
the European Economic Area
this means Polish or Spanish farmers
cannot sell all the milk that they want
to sell there is a maximum quota imposed
by Brussels and you can probably guess
that oh yes this was a French invention
and it helps explain things like this
base price value of 7.4 billion euros in
2011 French agricultural production is
the leader in Europe to go help our for
decades and the following French
presidents capture this d richest model
at the end of the day during the 1960s
and 70s France was on fire so if
something works why don't you fix it
well actually now I'm going to tell you
exactly why you should fix it
[Music]
same solutions to a different problem
the problem starts when the rest of the
world is running sauce to the new we're
of course talking about the 80s and 90s
the Berlin Wall came down China started
opening up their economy and lots of new
countries like Spain and Greece became
members of the European Union and of
course all of these countries wanted to
sell their product in other words all of
a sudden France and rivals and this is
what explains why this kind of news is
quite so common furious French farmers
have been attacking Spanish fruit and
vegetable deliveries have effects of the
e.coli crisis continued to bite Spanish
producers have slashed their prices to
make up for huge losses and are now up
to 40 cents a kilo cheaper than their
French counterparts the same happens
with other industries take a look at
this chart that represents the trade
balance in France
[Music]
if you pay attention you can see how
after the 90s exports are dropping
slowly this trend is especially true
after the financial crisis so maybe
remember
Alcatel mobile phone these were mobile
phones that were really popular when
mobile phones were just becoming a thing
Alcatel was an absolute juggernaut in
this industry and now they've simply
disappeared in a market dominated by
American Chinese and South Korean
companies and this is just one example
of how France is losing their ability to
innovate and so now you might be
wondering what of all the French
government's done to tackle this problem
well really they just protected their
companies from the rest of the world for
an opposite example let's look at Sweden
he makes Volvo cars what a Chinese
company wanted to buy this firm the
Swedish government didn't intervene at
all in Sweden there was a clear
separation between business and the
state but we cannot say the same of
France just have a look at what happens
when Pepsi wanted to buy known in 2005
some Luis bollo the Labour Minister said
the government will do all we can to
oppose a bid and Thierry Britain
the finance minister pledged to protect
dan on but this is not the only thing
that doesn't change in France their
social spending is still the highest in
the European Union even larger than that
of the Nordic country and further the
French administration employs more civil
servants than any other European country
oh and their salaries are also pretty
enormous so basically France of the
lower income imagine the past but they
keep spending like they did here in the
glory days this explains why their
public debt is quite as large as it is
but things they might just be on the
verge of change
groans quiet revolution
all right so politicians the promise a
lot during elections and they don't
always deliver on those promises that
there is something we have to admit in
the case of the Kronk his program is a
complete break with the French dirige
ISM all the political analysts have
labeled this man as at moderate
politician who wants to continue the
work of his predecessors but the big
question is is that really true
the truth is some of his proposals have
never even been put forward by another
French president from any side of the
political spectrum
it's precising a big reform program to
open up the series of services and
increased competition in terms of
projects in good markets transportation
and Sun for a better understanding in an
electoral campaign that became famous
because of the populist tone of missus
lepen mr. McCrone is proposing to retire
over 120,000 civil servants now many of
you might think that this is a pretty
horrible idea but there is something we
must admit basically being on it
there is no other politician who would
suggest such an unpopular thing during
an election nonetheless
Makram has won this election by often
doing the opposite of what a candidate
should supposedly do on his manifesto
you can even promise that he would never
reduce the retirement age in other words
macron is really committed to reducing
french public spending
on the other hands that macron combines
all of these budget cuts with lowering
taxes and helping small companies in his
own words McCrone wants to substitute
ooh french d ridges and with something
closer to the model of Germany or Sweden
where welfare states coexist with the
free market economy so now you might be
wondering even after winning the
elections does he have any actual power
to make this happen
in France the president doesn't have as
much power as the American president
Stan's every Lord wants to pass has to
go through Parliament and now the
question has to be who is leaves biggest
force in Parliament well that is
something we're not going to know until
the summer of 2017
in June French people are going to go
back to the voting stations and this
time they're voting in legislative
elections and it is hears at the party
of marine lepen the National Front has a
better chance of becoming the main force
[Music]
but what does the French fry right
actually what well if you'd like to know
more about that you should definitely
check out one of our previous videos
which you can click on right there and
now the big question is the human even
even this quiet revolution of Emmanuel
macron do you believe that you can pull
France out of the hole do you think
French stagnation has a solution well
you can leave your answer in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you don't forget we publish brand new
videos every Monday and the research day
so don't forget to hit that subscribe
button so you won't miss any posts and
if you liked this video please do give a
thumbs up below and we'll also liked the
tank see you we consider media podcasts
for providing the voice and vocals for
this episode and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]